thank you adam as i was saying to all of
you audience are just going to bring in
here now somebody who knows the uk
economy better than pretty much anybody
else he also happens to be the man who's
galvanizing the financial sector uh
ahead of that big push towards net zero
at cop26 so i'm going to introduce you
now to dr mark carney mark really good
to see you this morning i appreciate you
getting up super early at canadian time
to speak to us
i wanted to start by talking to you mark
if i may about cop 26 just over two
weeks to go i know you've been working
very hard towards it
prince charles says there's a chance it
could just be all talk how confident are
you that we'll see some action at that
conference
well first it's great to see you sam and
thanks for having me uh
we are seeing action uh we need to see
more but we are seeing big action and as
you know i'm concentrating on the
private financial sector so city of
london but really the global financial
sector and there's two big things we
need to do for cop the first is to
change the i'll use a metaphor the
plumbing of the system so the
information the tools create some new
markets there's 24 very wonky detailed
things that needed to be done for a cop
they're all going to be completed for
glasgow so that's the first thing and
that what that does is it reorients the
system to
uh providing capital to move towards net
zero or where our economy needs to go
where the world needs to go the second
big thing we need to do is to get a very
large amount of money
that is going to be lent and invested
towards that net zero to help drive our
economy forward but also help get
emissions down and as we meet today uh
the number of banks insurers uh big
pension funds around the world who've
committed to that
that number 18 months ago was five
trillion dollars five trillion today
it's over 90 trillion nine zero trillion
dollars and so there's been an enormous
shift in that uh in the run-up to [ __ ]
we're continuing to build that uh
momentum into cops so that we have
enough money
that's needed for the investment uh to
make the transition so i think we're
seeing more a lot more than talk
but but you in order for it to be a
success you need the big countries there
the big finances there particularly the
big emitters is china coming can it be a
success without them yeah um so we need
we need many things there's no one
solution as you well know and uh you're
absolutely right we need the countries
to step up um and uh just in the
shorthand what we're trying to achieve
for cop is that the ambition of
countries the policies of con countries
and then of course the actions of
companies
and uh banks and others is consistent
with one and a half degrees limiting
temperature increases to one and a half
degrees
right now we're not on that trajectory
uh the commitments of countries are
estimated to add up to 2.1 degrees
that's better than it was a few years
ago but it's not good enough um so we
need to see additional progress china
itself has moved very importantly in the
last 12 months it committed to net zero
that was a first for a major emerging
economy and it's made some additional
commitments around coal in recent months
uh we need to see more from them we need
to see more candidly from virtually
everybody yeah but if canada and
australia and other big emitter don't
come
it doesn't give you that urgency that
you need does it well um what we have is
that in recent months um canada for
example went from a 30 percent objective
to a 45 objective by 2030 so a different
path for emissions uh we saw an increase
the u.s stepped up for the first time
going to 50 down by 2030 their
objectives so all of those big so-called
g7 countries have been moving the you
know the prime minister and others have
been working very hard on this aspect of
it so we're getting movement in some of
the big advanced economies look sam they
have to deliver and one of the ways they
can deliver is to have that finance that
that money that i was talking about
earlier being lined up and then put to
work
there is more momentum
than perhaps meets the eye and let me
give you one other figure which is
important
18 months ago uk started the presidency
less than one-third of global emissions
were covered by these net zero
commitments such as the uk has now it's
more than three quarters so there's been
a huge shift in 18 months again we need
to
continue with that momentum and get more
into glasgow which is why we're meeting
and mark i know you're advising the
prime minister um the uk clearly needs
to set an example here we're hosting the
conference
um its own independent committee has
been critical of the uk government's
lack of plan are you aware of a detailed
uk government plan to get us to net zero
well first thing to say and i have
the opportunity to see approaches around
the world given my role and the uk's
overall approach is absolutely the right
one in the following respects one it has
a very clear objective secondly it has
as you say an independent committee
which assesses how good our policies are
relative to that objective and what that
committee the climate change committee
is saying is that there's a gap between
what we're saying is our objective and
where the policies are
and it's identifying the size of that
gap now that's okay in the sense of
there are always other budgets there's
always additional plans and there's
additional things being put in place and
the uk has been stepping up whether it's
on wind whether it's on the
moratorium on internal combustion
engines
whether it's on hydrogen the hydrogen
economy yes more needs to be done but we
have a much better idea in the uk
where the gap is between ambition and
action
and governments can put forward i would
stress it again as well that the uk
financial system and that's not just our
banks but very much our insurers and
pension funds have moved hugely and in
many respects are leading us and this
can help pull forward the adjustment
that the governments need to make but
government climate policy needs to be
credible doesn't it mark is it helpful
that there is an inquiry as to whether
we should be
building a new coal mining cumbria and
doing oil and gas exploration up in
scotland
yeah well i think uh let me let me put
it this way i think it is helpful that
an inquiry is being done into this and
independent inquiry is being done to
this because it shows exactly what the
issues are around the transition uh
let's take the example of the uh of the
coal uh mine in cumbria which is cold
being used for steel not coal being used
for power generation but still has an
environmental impact if it's done uh
there is a gap between um the life of
that coal mine it could run until 2050
effectively uh the life of that coal
mine and what
our trajectory needs to be in the uk in
order to get to net zero a coal mine
like that really can only run in the
judgment of that independent panel until
2035 so what it does this approach is it
shines a light on
how we need to change and it forces us
to think much more carefully about
putting in place
new investments in carbon intensive
sectors
and much greater intent
focus on transitioning from you know the
old economy to the new economy in a way
that's growing our growing jobs and uh
and income in terms of credibility mark
wouldn't it have just been easier just
to say no we're not going there
uh well i think look i i'm not a member
of the government they have to follow a
process there's a judicial review
quasi-judicial review i guess is the way
i would put it the decision was called
in by the by the government the national
government from the from the local level
it's being reviewed my understanding is
that that decision will happen by the
end of this year so you
we have to respect process in these
things um and uh i i would suggest that
the pro the process and the fact we're
talking about and it gets out the you
know the realities of what a transition
is and where we need to go uh is
actually
you know hey it's the right thing to do
you have to follow due process as i say
but it also brings to life uh the real
issues underlying this
final question on this before we get on
on to the financing which is i i know
what you'd like to talk about a style
point some of the language used by the
prime minister around green issues bunny
huggers quoting kermit the frog does
that kind of language help with
illustrating the urgency of what you're
trying to achieve on the environment
uh it's certainly it's certainly
memorable um and um
the prime minister does
range widely in terms of his metaphors
and uh but he's uh if there's not
language you'd be using you're not going
to be quoting kermit the frog yourself
no okay all right i sense uh you've said
all you want to say on that let's talk
about the climate finance then um
falling short of what was pledged in
copenhagen 100 billion dollars a year
for developing nations is it the united
states that's holding things up because
they seem to have the biggest
bridge to build here
yeah so the first thing to say is for
anyone coming to this new or not
following a day-to-day the numbers are
absolutely enormous so um what you're
asking about is as you know a hundred
billion dollars a year this was a pledge
of uh the rich countries basically to
help the poor countries developing
economies with the transition it was
made 10 years ago in copenhagen and we
haven't met it yet and it's one of the
key objectives for the uk for this for
glasgow for cop is to get to that number
now
two weeks ago there was the meeting of
the u.n general assembly prime minister
was there um and uh actually the u.s
stepped up they doubled their commitment
to over 11 billion i think it's 11.4
billion uh dollars
there are a number of other countries
who are looking to potentially add to
theirs canada and germany are managing a
process not me personally but others
managing a process to get to that
hundred billion number it's very
important but at the same time and i
apologize to your audience
just to put it in context we need to
multiply that by a thousand
uh in terms of additional uh
capital additional finance in other
words we need not just a hundred billion
dollars we need a hundred trillion
dollars over the next uh two decades two
and a half decades in order to get to
where we need to go and the point that
we've recognized very early on is that's
only going to come from the private
sector which is why there's been such a
focus on the things i was talking about
at the start which is to get the private
sector aligned uh to move money towards
uh companies and projects that are
solutions to this problem yeah
while we've got you mark we're running
out of time i do want to ask you about
the uk economy quite a few spasms in it
at the moment we've got all the coveted
scarring of course cost of living crisis
uh energy crisis as well what's your
take
well uh the uk is going through as as
others are but maybe a little more
sharply the uk is going through a series
of
uh
supply shocks to use the economic term
uh we have the adjustment from covet and
acceleration of changes in business
whether it's on the digital side perhaps
most prominently
we have the big move in energy prices uh
which which we're seeing elsewhere but
more so in the uk which
brings its own impact
we have the aftermath of brexit and the
readjustment of the economy that comes
so we have all three of those factors
coming together um and it's uh it it
means by and and we have the beginnings
of this net zero transition we're really
at the early stages of it uh and it
means that um uh there are there are
some frictions in the economies and and
and adjustments that are necessary
can i ask you as well i can't resist
really i mean the supply chain ruptures
labor shortages disputes over the good
friday agreement
do you feel like one of those derided
experts who was opining on these things
in the run-up to the referendum back in
2016 who now feels a bit like i told you
so
absolutely i mean i i our job the bank
of england's job and the run-up uh to
both the referendum but very much to
brexit itself was to make sure the
financial system was in a position to be
part of the solution i think what we
have seen
is that the financial system uk
financial system has stood up as a
through this period including of
disruption and what at least i'm doing
and working with others including the
bank of england the treasury
more broadly is making sure the
financial system is ready
and part of the solution for climate
change so moving on to the next big
thing
and and that's what we can do of course
part of making sure that it was ready
was to look at what could go wrong in
the types of supply chains and uh
inflationary and other impacts that
could come uh from the uh the adjustment
the initial phase of adjustment and uh i
i think what people can
look it may be cold comfort to some
extent but uh you know be reassured that
the uk financial system is very strong
uh and uh it's part of the solution both
in the short term
and what we're doing for glasgow is
making sure that it is part of the
solution
for this transition towards net zero and
the last point if i may and that is the
transition that will i saw it at graphs
earlier that will continue to grow this
economy uh
at a speed that people expect i noticed
you sidestepped there with that the
whole i told you so at some point but
but we'll move on um calls from the
energy industry for state support and
also energy intensive businesses um
wanting state support i know i don't
want to drag you into uk government
policy but given the urgency of the
environmental problem is it even
appropriate for that conversation to be
being had
well i think what um
short-term moves uh underscore is that
we need a comprehensive plan for the
transition
there are
and we need to try to have a transition
that is smoother rather than choppy
and
so part of that is that policy that you
were talking about earlier we needed to
be predictable and credible um in terms
of energy policy uh in addition um
sometimes it is appropriate for some
support particularly for the users of
energy uh in in those sectors
but i i yes as you suggested in your
preamble i'd leave it to the government
who's much closer to these issues to
make those determinations
uh and final question uh thought from
you mark in paris the notable
achievement was to get countries to dare
to imagine that maximum temperature
increase of of one and a half degrees
what do you think could be the headline
from glasgow
i think uh absolutely we've got to keep
one and a half degrees alive um so
imagination is one thing and vision is
one thing but action is what's needed
so we have a few more weeks
we will do everything we can on the
financial sector to ensure that there's
real action and commitment so that the
money is there
what's clear is that the money is there
for the transition that's one core plank
we need for glasgow the second is that
countries step up uh not just with
ambition but with policy that uh meets
that ambition i said final question i do
have one more for you i mean you talk
about the green recovery inclusive
growth the multiplier effect kicking in
um
that's going to mean an end to historic
low interest rate rises isn't it so the
whole world's going to have to adjust to
that
well um a couple of things one is that
we have been in a very difficult place
for the last decade uh since the
financial crisis with exceptionally low
in uh interest rates in order to keep
our economy going uh effectively it's
been the right policy
but it's not a desirable place to be and
the only way to move out of that is to
have bigger structural changes and very
positive ones which mean a lot of
investment we need an additional two
percentage points of gdp that's an
enormous amount of investment
in order to make this transition it is
feasible we've got the money now in
order to make it
but that will help to
grow first the economy secondly and
relatedly incomes and jobs of people and
in that
positive environment then it would be
appropriate to have higher interest
rates um to keep the economy going all
else equal but that's a good this is
this is good news
and by the way it's good news for savers
it's good news for a lot of people uh
but it is not uh being punished by
higher interest rates it's a consequence
of positive outcomes so yes i i hope we
get there um we've got some more work to
do in until we do though
all right it's been fascinating talking
to you this morning mark again thank you
for getting up early to speak to us we
look forward to seeing you in glasgow at
cop26 and wishing you all the best of
luck with it thank you very much indeed